Underneath It All is just I wonder why
there is so much hate against groups why
it's such a sticky way of
thinking not just tribalism like proud
of your country and kind of hating
another country but really deeply hating
like hating in a way where it's part of
your identity kind of
hate well just to make a general point
on this issue in our conversation here
today you often talk about individual
leaders and the word individual often
pops up in your vocabulary yes I believe
that we are ultimately social animals
before we are individuals I believe
we're born into tribes we're heavily
socialized and that we carve out space
for our
individualism but we are part of tribes
and or social groups or nations call
them what you want ethnic groups
religious groups but the fact is that
these tribes often crash into each other
and when they crash into each other uh
they end up hating each other uh if you
go to a place like Bosnia right the
croats and the serbs oh my God and then
throw in the
bosniacs which is the term for Bosnian
Muslims and you know Muslims croats
serbs uh oh
and uh the tribes you know hate each
other uh and uh in a funny way that
hatred almost never goes away uh and uh
I guess there are some exceptions to
that uh if you look at the Germans after
World War II they've gone a long way
towards reducing I wouldn't want to say
completely eliminating but reducing a
lot of the hatred uh that existed
between Germans and their neighbors uh
but that's really kind of an anomalous
case uh I mean you go around East Asia
today and the hatred of Japan in a place
like China the hatred of Japan in a
place like Korea just not to be
underestimated and uh so but I think a
lot of it just has to do with the fact
that you're dealing with social groups
that have crashed into each other uh at
one point or another and there are those
lingering effects and by the way this
gets back back to our discussion a few
minutes ago about trying to get a
two-state solution between the
Palestinians and the Israeli Jews now
that you have had uh this horrible War
uh which is
ongoing